- Alright, welcome back!
I'm here with the one and only, Cher!
Give it up!
(audience cheering happily)
Alright.
Well, what is this 1965
photo of you and Sonny
remind you of when you see this?
- Well, we were in the Hilton Hotel,
which we had been kicked
out of about a week before.
(laughing amusingly)
And we're just hanging out.
We'd done a PLUS Conference
and we're just hanging out.
- I love that you got...
What'd you get kicked out for?
(laughing amusingly)
- Well because if you
look the way we look,
people were trying to beat us up,
and they just were frightened of it.
- [Kelly Oh.
- They didn't understand
that it was nothing to be afraid of,
it was just new or different.
And that's why we went to England
because we couldn't really
get work in America.
- Wow, that's so...
Just, for me and my generation,
I just didn't know all of that.
And I obviously, grew up
in a different environment.
And so, it's just crazy to me
that you're known for being
such a powerful leader
in the fashion world,
and being so confident
in that, and being...
And when I mean fashion,
I mean like, real fashion.
Like, I don't really get into a lot of it,
but I love what you do.
I love all those Bob Mackie dresses.
I love all of that because
it's real true fashion.
It's like, it can be revealing,
but it can also be mysterious,
and it's beautiful,
and it's art.
And I think that it's
so crazy for me to think
that back in the day,
people were afraid of that,
but obviously it was a different time.
But, let's move on to the 1970s.
(bright upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
This 70s dress, oh my God, I love it.
(laughing happily) It's also the image
on the box of your 1970s fragrance.
- [Cher] Right.
(audience cheering happily)
- So, let's show that.
This is so great.
And it's a Bob Mackie dress, right?
- Oh, yeah.
That dress has been copied
by every woman I think living now.
(audience laughing amusingly)
And they haven't got it right though.
- Well, every woman
that could possibly wear
something like that.
'Cause I think it would look
rather different on me, Cher.
(audience laughing relatably) I mean...
- Look how young Bob looks.
- That's a beautiful...
- It is a beautiful dress.
- [Kelly] I know.
- And it's made out of a material
that is illegal in America
because you know magician's paper,
and it just goes up like that?
Well, so does that dress.
(audience exclaiming worryingly)
- So, wait, wait, wait, wait.
(laughing amusingly)
So like, if anyone was like...
A cigarette around you, like it-
- Absolutely.
- Oh my God!
What you do for art and beauty.
Oh, that's crazy!
And also, very rock and roll.
And of course, it was like
flammable, you're so awesome.
That's literally one of my favorite things
that you've ever worn, it's so cool.
- No, it's my favorite.
I have another one though.
- Oh, is it?
What's your favorite?
- Well, that's my favorite.
But, one of my other favorites
is the one with the big giant feathers,
the black one with the big giant feathers.
(audience applauding happily)
- Wait, is this...
Okay, I'm gonna get to
that one in a minute
'cause I love that one as well.
(audience cheering happily)
But, is it...
'Cause I'm gonna get to
that one, that one's cool.
You have so many cool
ones, it's ridiculous.
But, I have to ask this 'cause
I remembered hearing this
and I was like, "I gotta
ask her in an interview,"
is it sure that Jennifer Aniston
would come over to play at
your house as a little girl
in the 70s?
- As a teenager, I mean as
like, a middle teenager.
And eat me outta house and home.
(audience laughing amusingly)
And it's like the kids, the
girls always used to, you know,
they knew when I would went to Balducci,
and they would just show
up and just chow down.
And she was a big chow downer.
(audience laughing amusingly)
- I love it!
I didn't know.
I just think that's so funny.
Nobody knows that behind the scenes
of like how people that you don't know
are related in some way, in some capacity,
like back in the day.
That's so cool to me.
Did anybody know that she was acting
and gonna do anything
like that at that age?
'Cause she was so young.
- No, I mean she was
going to school, you know,
she was going to High
School of Performing Arts.
And this is one thing that I know,
it's like when my mom used
to say to anybody she met,
"I have a daughter who sings."
Well, the minute you say
that, people just turn it off.
And Ahmet Ertegun,
the big manager and owner
of Atlantic Records,
my mom said, "I have
a daughter who sings,"
and he said, "Yes, Georgia, that's good."
And then, he signed us
and then we're singing.
And one night, my mom
comes in and he said,
"Georgia, what are you doing here?"
And she said, "I told you I
have a daughter that sings,
there she is."
(audience laughing amusingly)
- Oh my God!
That's so true though because I mean,
you've had to have that
happen so many times too.
I do too.
They're always like,
"Oh, my daughter sings,"
or, "Oh, my son sings."
And they always like, think
there's some kind of magical way
I can make it happen for them.
Does that happen to you a lot of times?
'Cause I'm like, "Look,
it's just sometimes,
you're there in a studio, and
somebody's car breaks down,
and you're singing the BGV,
and you get in that way,"
You know, like, "You do it, darlin'."
You just never know how it's gonna happen.
So, don't you get that a lot though?
People saying all the
time, like, "My kid sings"?
- Yeah.
And sometimes-
- [Kelly] I know, I get that too.
- Sometimes, you see them
later, you know, on TV,
and sometimes you can do something,
but most times you can't.
- I know, that's what I'm saying.
It's always a hard thing to be like,
"Man, you just gotta
say yes to everything,
and get out there and do it
'cause you never know
what your chance will be,"
or whatever.
- Right.
- But now, we're heading into the 1980s.
(bright upbeat music returns)
(audience applauding happily)
"Turn Back Time"
is also the slogan from
your fragrance collection,
which is just so clever.
(audience cheering supportively)
But, what do you remember
about that song and that video?
'Cause I feel like sometimes artists,
people don't know the
stories that go behind songs,
when we like end up saying yes
and we end up recording them.
So, what happened with that song,
how'd that song come to you?
- Diane Warren wrote it.
And she brought it to me
and I didn't wanna do it.
(audience laughing gently)
No, she was doing the demo,
and she is not exactly a singer
that you wanna listen to.
And so I kept saying no.
(audience laughing gently)
(laughing amusingly)
I kept saying, no, no, and no.
And then, she said,
"I'll pay for it if it
doesn't turn out great."
Well,
knowing Diane is the cheapest
woman that ever drew breath-
(audience laughing gently)
I said, "Okay, I gotta do this
'cause I just gotta do it."
And the moment I started,
the song just sung itself,
do you know what I mean?
I opened my mouth
and the song just came
out and sung itself.
- I'll tell you what, man,
she's one hell of a writer,
but she's also very bold.
Like, when she sends a song.
- Oh, yes.
- She was like, "You are
stupid if you don't do this."
(laughing amusingly)
You're like, "Okay, okay."
- Babe, she followed me into an AA meeting
to sell me a song.
(audience laughing amusingly)
(laughing loudly)
No sorry, no, it was an Al-Anon meeting.
It was an Al-Anon
meeting, and she came in,
and somebody said, "You
know, are you here,"
you know, blah-blah-blah.
She said, "No, I just wanna see Cher
'cause I have a song I want her to hear."
And they kicked her out.
(audience laughing amusingly)
- I know, but you know what,
there's one thing I'll give
that woman, she is persistent.
But, she writes a lotta
great songs, so there's that.
So, what do you remember about that video,
making that video?
It's so iconic.
- Well, I remember Bob saying,
"Don't tell anybody I made this."
(Kelly laughing amusingly)
And when I see it, I think,
"You might have gone a little
bit too far this time."
But, whatever.
And so, I just...
Also, we did so many different things.
I went around in a speedboat,
and then I climbed up the side of the,
you know, of the Missouri, and came...
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I mean, we did everything,
all they used was that.
All they used was that.
(audience laughing amusingly)
And my son's in it.
And it's just, look, it's bold.
It might be past bold, it's
crass, but I don't care.
(audience applauding and
cheering supportively)
- I gotta be honest with you,
like I actually really dug it.
I thought it was awesome, and
an incredible domino effect
I think in a positive
way for a lotta people.
I thought it was rad.
Now, I can't wear that (beep),
but like you can and it
looks good. (laughing warmly)
(audience applauding supportively)
Not everybody's blessed.
- No, no.
But you know, it was, for me,
it's never been a statement of
how far I can push something.
It's always been a statement of,
"This is what I want to do."
And let me tell you, you
know, the dress that we saw,
the one that blows up?
(audience laughing amusingly)
That was on the cover of Time Magazine.
In the South, they ripped the cover off.
So, you know how far-
- [Kelly] Oh my G...
Well, that's not shocking.
- Yeah. (laughing understandably)
(audience laughing amusingly)
- Yeah.
(audience cheering supportively)
You had two iconic looks this decade
that we're talking about.
So, you already talked
about this one from 1986.
So, this is another one you loved, right?
- Yes.
Bob designed that for
me, but I had the idea.
And I asked him to do it
because the academy said
that (laughing gently) the men I chose
were not appropriate and that
my clothing was inappropriate.
So, I thought, "You think that's bad?
Wait till you see this."
(audience laughing relatably)
- I love that, I love
that. (laughing amusingly)
I love that.
- Wait, wait, I'm gonna
tell you something,
I'm gonna tell you something!
So, I was presenting something, right?
And, oh no, I was going to present.
And I was going around the back
and it's all black duvetyne,
which is like black velvet
and you can't see anything.
But when you're back there,
and if you've been in front of the lights,
you can't see anything.
So, I'm going around, I'm going around,
and I run into Jane Fonda.
(laughing amusingly) And she
looks at me and she goes,
"I have got to get to my seat
before you get on stage, okay?
I just have to see this."
(audience laughing amusingly)
So...
(audience applauding enjoyably)
- Well, I love that moment,
and it was very cool for a lot of us.
And finally though, I
wanna talk about the 90s.
(bright upbeat music returns)
(audience applauding happily)
So, this is like the
time I like grew up in,
that I love music and
all that kinda stuff.
So, how did the song
"Believe" come to you?
'Cause it's such an iconic song.
- Okay, first I got dropped
by my record company.
And a man in England who
ran Warner's UK said,
"I believe in you," and, "Come
to me and I will help you."
So, I got "Believe,"
and the chorus was great
but the verse was terrible.
And so, my producer, who I'd
never had a cross word with,
kept saying, "You have to sing it better,
you have to sing it better."
(laughing amusingly) And I said,
"Babe, if you want it sung
better, get somebody else."
So then, I left.
And then, the next day he said,
"You know, I've been playing
around with the pitch machine
and I think I might have something."
So, I went in and I sat next to him,
and he started to play it.
And it was unbelievable
because there was never anything like it.
And when it was done, we
high fived each other.
And then, the people from the
record company who I love,
and the Germans, I don't
know why they were in there,
but anyway, they were.
Oh, I can't say this.
So, they said, "Well, no,
we don't know it's you."
And I went, (laughing
happily) "Exactly, exactly."
In the beginning and
it spiced up the verse,
and it just sailed, you know?
And then, they said, "You can't have it.
And I said.... Well, can you bleep this?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- It's my show, we can
do whatever you want.
- Okay, so anyway, I said,
"Okay, you can take it out
over my dead (beep) body."
(audience cheering loudly)
(laughing amusingly)
- But, thank you so much
for taking us through those decades.
This is such a cool, rad perfume line.
I love it so much.
I love the whole backstory of it all.
(laughing happily) But everybody,
Cher is celebrating each
decade of her iconic career
with a unique fragrance
that conveys the feelings
of the 60s, 70s, 80s, and 90s,
like we were just talking about,
with four timeless scents.
See what we did there?
And everyone here will
get to enjoy those scents
because you're all
going home with a bottle
from "Cher Decades" eau de parfum!
(Kelly imitating horn blowing)
(audience cheering ecstatically)